One of the most common questions I get asked as a tribe wife
is if I vote. And the answer is yes,
I do. I consider it my responsibility as an American citizen,
and this election especially
is one of the most important of my lifetime.
If you've been following my pregnancy,
you'll know that I was basically on bed rest for four months,
too sick to go anywhere.
I wasn't sure if I would make it to my own baby shower,
much less to go vote. But then I found out I can vote early in person,
which means I'm not limited to just election Day.
Pregnancy has caused me to have to be super flexible.
And that is just what early voting is.
I can cast my ballot on my schedule
and not have to worry about being too sick day of. No,
election day is the deadline,
not the start. So I'm gonna vote early and in person
and give myself the best chance to make sure my vote is counted
and avoid last minute issues by casting my ballot ahead of time
in person. And
I feel good
that this release a little bit of pressure on the poll workers, too.
So if you're like me,
not sure how easy it will be for you to go vote on Election Day,
maybe this is a good option for you too.
And for the naysayers, no,
my husband doesn't tell me who to vote for.